functions are one of the fundamental
building blocks of JavaScript a function
is a JavaScript procedure which is just
a set of statements that performs a task
or calculates a value to use a function
you must define it somewhere in the
scope from which you want to call it a
function definition which is also called
a declaration or function statement
consists of the function keyword so in
this example here's the function keyword
and then there's also going to be the
name of the function which is square in
this case so you're always going to this
keyword function it's always going to be
function the name is always going to be
different and this function is called
square because that's what we're going
to do in the function we're going to
square a number now you're also going to
have a list of arguments to the function
enclosed in parentheses so the argument
and this function is number this is a
what we're going to pass in to the
function these are called parameters
which are variables that act as
placeholders for the values that are to
be input into a function when it is
called so you're going to input or pass
these values into the function so when
you call the function you are going to
write the root you're going to type the
word square but you're not going to type
the word number you are going to pass in
a number and this becomes a variable
within the scope of the function the
last thing that function hat is going to
have which is the main body part of the
function are the statements that define
the function these are unclosed in these
curly brackets so some folks want some
functions we'll have a lot of lines this
one just has one line and you can see
the return keyword that's going to
return something from the function when
you call the squared function it's going
to return number times number which is
how you square a number you multiply a
number by itself so here's how you could
call that function I'm going to pass in
that function into console.log so we can
log the the answer to that function I'm
going to put square four and when we run
that we can see it's going to log 16
we're going to call Square which is the
function instead of the word number
we're going to pass in four and it's
going to return
number times number which is four times
four and then when we kill console that
log with this returns okay here's
another another function and I'm going
to use this as an example to explain
scope in JavaScript scope refers to the
visibility of variables so variables
that are defined outside of a function
block have a global scope so here's the
actual function the function is my fun
we're not going to pass in any variables
or parameters or arguments and it's just
going to cancel that log some var which
is defined before the function so
because this variable is defined before
the function it is a global variable and
so then the func the variable can be
accessed inside the functions however
variables which are declared within a
function as well as the function
parameters have local scope that means
they're only visible within that
function so let's call mine fun and so
that's how you would call a function
that does not have any parameter
anything you have to put parentheses
after the name of the function
if we run there and you can see it's
going to a console dot log hat even
though hat is not within the function so
a variable defined within the function
is a local variable so a local variable
can actually have the same name as a
global variable so here's some we have
our sambar equals hat bar some bar
equals shoes these are the same name so
when they have the same name a local
variable is going to take precedence
over the global variable so if we run
that it's going to say shoes over here
but now if we do console.log some bar
and we're going to run that so it's
going to cancel out log shoes here but
when I console dot log some bar again
it's going to cancel that log hat
because this is a local variable and
it's not accessible from outside the
function so when I try to console that
log the variable outside the function
we're console logging the global
variable that we define outside the
function and now I'm going to talk about
nesting a function within another
function so when you nest a function
within another function or when you put
a function inside a function the nested
or inner function is private to its
containing outer function so in this
example we have the function add square
and the this function is this whole
block here but inside that function is
another function the function is square
so the inner function which is square
can only be accessed from the statements
in the outer function so you can see
this inner function square we're
accessing it here we're calling the
inner function here and here if we were
um here and we called square it wouldn't
work we get error because that's outside
of the function the inner function can
be only accessed within the function
that it's in the inner function forms a
closure the inner function the inner
function can use the arguments and
variables of the outer function while
the outer function cannot use the
arguments of variables of the inner
function learn more about closures in my
closure video is going to equal ads when
we're going to pass and two values two
and three so we'll be passed n two and
three here now we're going to ignore
this for now because we're not calling
it yet but now we're going to return
square okay here we aren't calling it
we're going to pass in a which is going
to be two and it's going to square it
two times two is four now we're going to
add that and we're going to call square
again we're going to pass in B which is
three so it's going to pass them three
and do 3 times 3 which is 9 so now we
have 4 plus 9 equals 13 and that's in
return 13 you could console that login
or user in another function we also can
do this if you pass in 3 & 4 you get 25
you're passing 4 & 5 you can get 41
another thing to know is that a function
declaration is hoisted that means no
matter where it is in the code it's kind
of brought up to the top of the
odhh so let me show you what I mean by
that
so look what I did here I cancel that
log and then calling the add squares
function which actually isn't defined
until right after that line over here so
I'm passing in 1 3 1 squared is 1 3
squared is 9 1 1 plus 9 is 10 and it's
going to counter that log 10 so you can
call a function before it is actually
appears in the code see my hosting video
for more information about that well
that's the basics of functions thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good